laughs
[Music]
not very often man we have goats in the
clinic well usually we all chasing goats
right it's a lot easier to have them
come inside in a controlled environment
no no no no no no correction yeah me
I'll Chase can go I ain't done this one
I'm coming Kayla good job kid all right
having them inside in a controlled
environment because it really stresses
me man to see you running around behind
those animal plants so it stresses you
yes that I'm running behind the group
yes that's true
I just man you just you're wearing me
out
[Music]
on this afternoon goats come in from
pasture for a visit to the doctor's
office hello Dana how you doing I'm
great how are you all right so you
bought some babies today we did four in
total all right we want to have
everybody tested see if they have worms
we're hoping that the females might be
pregnant I have my goats we have brought
them up here today for a wellness check
one of our other notes had had worms and
I'm hoping that the two females are
either pregnant or are healthy and
capable to get pregnant how old is she
we think she's about three okay or it
sounds good yeah we got a pretty big
stomach here but we are rooming an
animal sometimes they're just big but
we'll see if she got some babies in
there
okay she looks pretty good we're gonna
get a stew sample from her okay and what
we'll do is take this stew sample and
we'll take it inside and float it in a
special solution and then we're trying
to find eggs in there okay
yeah but you got some fresh over there
see you just fell out over there to the
left
yeah no problem getting samples here
that's right they're like oh you want it
here have it that's right you got plenty
of sample all over here about a year and
a half all right so what we're going to
do shake it inside try to get an x-ray
and then we're going to set up our fecal
flotation you're gonna follow mama you
can follow mommy probably not
it's gonna probably gonna be a drag the
entire way
just in time buddy what you doing
bringing a goat to you I know I'm going
to go you're the greatest of all all
greatest of all time I have to go okay
we got a couple goes here that
impossibly pregnant okay okay so we want
to shoot her next couple of them
go
x-rated tailor these goes to practice
man you can't even tell the time of day
it's hard to tell the time of day when
you watch them both times inside of a
cow or a llama so I still could tell
better than you I'm gonna bit this guy
we're gonna decide if these girls are
pregnant or not let me see pregnant not
pregnant I tell you what the lunch lunch
what'd you think
you call this one I'll call the next one
uh
[Music]
uh I was hoping I could see the screen
push me another room no not pregnant not
crazy you know what you call them yeah
you won either that or it's too early
but I don't see anything in there one
for one who's to go now baby well you do
smell a little goatee oh man well I tell
you what lunch say you can't do it again
so what you calling on the next one the
next one avocado pregnant double or
nothing you the big Guru here today okay
all right all right I don't think I see
anything let's see here so I'm gonna
guess this one is not pregnant well you
just lost buddy
[Music]
I'm gonna go away
two for two I am the greatest you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah I am the greatest
budget I'm gonna give you a prize too
what's that you get to check the fecal
sound that's too much love that's just
for you bro thanks man all right let's
check this food sample here
all right so we do have strong owls like
hookworms and dogs or sponge outs so
Paul we need to get some meds on board
here all right I'll go and talk to her
about it okay okay
as Paul gathers Medicine Dr Ferguson
breaks the news to the goat's owner all
right sorry no pregnancies it's okay
it'll happen eventually just as I'm
suspected we do have parasite okay we're
gonna get us some parasite medication
and we're gonna do it daily for five
days all right that's a liquid in the
mouth in the mouth unfortunately our
goats aren't pregnant but um I
definitely feel much better that I know
that even though they do have parasites
that it's manageable and they're going
to be happy and healthy so what's on
we'll get it together for you and bring
it back out too perfect okay all right
be right back okay
see you later
have fun
I guess it's time for lunch I saw the
X-ray I mean I missed seeing I didn't
get a chance to see this right
cheated
[Music]
Dr Ferguson and vet tech Jordan make a
trip out to Nicole's rescue to treat the
latest animals she's been rehabbing the
weirdest ever had was a brown recluse
spider yes are your friends were
probably envious if you you have a brown
recluse spider yeah I just thought I had
this cool little brown spider I'm gonna
be the Spider Woman I think I want a cow
though you know just one maybe two yeah
you need two so they're not normal yeah
you got some land to do it don't you
yeah you know since all the kids don't
know just Kim and I I know you sad am I
sad are you sad about it no not yet I
don't think so and I call you sir oh
Jordan can I get a brown recluse I want
a spider or something I want to see some
of my kids over there
hahaha
hello Nicole
hey guys what you got going on you
working here today yeah something tried
to get into the pigeon pin I'm the CEO
of wildlife Critter circle of life my
main goal is to rescue rehabilitate and
release the animals back into the wild
my ferret is really sick oh what's going
on well it was my fattest ferret and
then he just started dropping weight all
right let's go see the baby okay the
ferret Oscar came to me from a hoarder
hey buddy come here what's up Oscar he
said I miss my friend the last couple
weeks he dropped weight and it's very
scary because there's no visual symptoms
his hair looks normal it's just weight
let's take a listen here
I can feel you stand yeah it's horrible
rapid weight loss and fear is really
concerned me but not that large to start
with even if we lose a couple grams or
even a pound that's very significant
percentage of weight loss and it can
cause a whole array of things to go
wrong
1.74 pounds so the last time I weighed
him was three two wow wow yeah that's a
lot we need to do some Diagnostics and
figure out what causes weight loss in
this baby I definitely want to get a
stool sample okay to make sure that not
some parasitic going on we need poop
let's go navigate through your cage
let's see what we can find here I'm sure
you got something somewhere in here oh
there we go we got it good for a sample
since we're on poop Patrol here we can
kind of evaluate this poop it looks good
you know the color is good it doesn't
like any blood in and it's formed so
that's a good sign we take it put it in
a special solution and if there are eggs
in there it floats to the top and will
sit on the microscope okay
when I'm waiting on test results
sometimes Jordan sings first one sorry I
can't say I'm not that I just you know
he likes the same thing he's a rapper
yeah he's profound the third is sick and
he's not feeling well I need to bring
him out of his shell and I wish him well
okay I'm sorry you need Dr Hodges keep
your day job
go through the slide in a systematic
approach because it only takes one egg
for me to see it to know that it's there
so I make sure that I cover the whole
slide and I have and good news I don't
see any parasites no worms no worms so
takes us to our next step run some
chemistry run some blood and see if
we're dealing with adrenal issues
I'm very pleased that Dr Ferguson
means that it is something more serious
and we do have to wait to find out what
is really going on with Oscar you
you should have results back in a couple
days okay and depending on where we are
we'll talk about treatments like
implants and things like that so we'll
go with that once we get the results
back okay Dr
Hydra Ferguson have been
since because they have become the
facility vet thank you all right always
taking care of my babies yeah you have a
good one okay we're a donation only
facility and by them coming and caring
for the animals they get even more of a
second chance if it wasn't for Dr
Ferguson coming out I don't know how I
would be able to help them bye buddy bye
bye ice cream man
foreign
yeah I'll get it
Good Samaritans Taylor and Teresa bring
in a unique hit and run victim they
found on the side of the road
around I mean
oh it's gorgeous any dog hey let's see
if we can figure out what's going on
with it
I know hey
all right we're here because we had
rescued an owl last night that was in
the road we couldn't leave him there you
know to get hit by a car and went and
got a box and went back in and got him
and put him in there to bring him I
think his leg is injured because his
wings kept going out but he couldn't go
anywhere
he's beautiful isn't he
is but it was like he didn't try to move
or anything it was like you knew we were
trying to help him I'm gonna go back in
see if I can figure out maybe shoot a
picture of this I'll give me one second
okay okay in my 20 years of Veteran
practice I've never treated a house we
are crew to fix the contrabands we treat
them all so if somebody brings an hour
I'm going to treat it go straight into
the X-ray or no let's look at his eyes
Let's do an exam one hey Mr my game plan
with this out is to examine it treat it
and get it to a rehab so it can get back
into the beautiful Georgia Skies
you took a nice shot to the head huh
no Reflex on this side yeah boy that eye
is not constricting at all it should
pinpoint and these guys can see a mile
away did you hit your cat or something
Buddy he took a shot definitely
typically just like with your physician
when we shine light into the eyes your
pupils should constrict and we'll remove
it it should kind of die and on the left
side just huge
let's hold this Wing up good job yeah
oh that's the way this pain is
the right leg
well up here Andrea
I need to hold these gloves so I found
this pain I think he did Broken Wings oh
no I think it's in here so I need you to
hold this pause for him gotcha somehow
let's get a picture here
is where he's ruffled in
yeah right above his leg right above his
leg
this bird is really showing signs of
concussion and bad pain so he's really
in bad shape
right right right
we really need to figure out the extent
of the damage because if it's too bad a
rehabber won't take it and without rehab
this bird won't make it got a little
pelvic fracture man looking at his skull
there's definitely a crack there but I'm
really worried about a concussion I mean
he he took a shot at this point I don't
know where this bird's gonna live
[Music]
Dr Hodges works on a concussed owl
hoping to get it rehabilitated back into
the wild you are seeing some Stars he is
out of it he didn't have a concussion
he'd be 10 I bust up you know when you
watch the cartoons in the little three
yeah
that's what this guy's seeing so this
bird does have a small fraction of
pelvis in the skull but those typically
will heal on his own well I'm really
concerned about this bird's concussion I
need to reduce the swelling on this
brain get you something for pain
under let me get some furosemite yes
and some pain medicine injectable
and we'll kind of go from there all of
us have a brain in the school we have
only so much space and when we have
trauma and it hits the brain and the
Brain starts swelling within that skull
you get some bleeds you have some
problems so I'm getting some furosemide
here in this muscle see if you got him
I'm giving some furosemite which
decreases the amount of swelling in the
brain and hopefully helps with this
concussion and this one goes po
basically per us Batman
there you go something for pain
such a gorgeous film I've done
everything I can for this owl but here's
an even bigger factor that would
determine if this bird survived Hey
Summer Omar the rehabber you know Omar
yeah
can you get them on the phone okay all
right and talk to him Omar has taken all
kinds of animals he's a fantastic
re-ever
everything from halts to raccoons never
or Aldo but I know Omar is the guy for
this job man I got a case here I never
had before well I have I know you picked
up Hawks and all this kind of stuff but
I got an owl rehabbers typically don't
take every animal in but if I can
convince him to take this out I feel
like there's a very good chance that
this I Will Survive I think he'd be a
good rehab candidate
okay today or tomorrow words boss thanks
so much I just got off the phone with
rehabit and the good news is he's
willing to take it and hopefully if it's
all he can be back in the Georgia Skies
before you want to go to the hospital
okay
Derek I got a new hospital patient for
you come on Derek is in charge of our
hospital room it's a dedicated area
where we keep animals that are
hospitalized or in intensive care so
I've treated this guy's percussion I've
treated the pain now we just got to let
this guy heal and hope for the best I
think you should keep him alive
[Music]
hey how are you today Nicole comes to
see Dr Ferguson to get the results of
Oscar the ferret's blood tests I don't
mean Oscar doing his weight is not good
but his energy is still good okay good
you should know if he has cushion
disease here
cushion disease is the cancer of the
adrenal glands so they're over secreting
enzymes but the body is not using it
okay so we're gonna put an implant in
we're basically giving what we call
exogenous hormones which means that
we're giving them from the outside so
that they can be used so it'll be just a
little incision inject through there and
put a little glue back on top okay
that'll be a adrenal gland implant
surgery sounds much scarier than it
really is Oscar man it's gonna be a new
man the implant does all the hard work
of regulating cortisone in the body we
just have to get it in all right big man
say no night no don't go right to it
Give It All To Me the reason we relax a
man it's needless it's kind of big for a
ferry this is our implant you can't see
it but it's in the needle here and it's
probably about the size of a rice grain
so interesting pretty big gauge needle
there kind of scary looking isn't it we
don't even use them at large and small
animal unless we're doing a microchip
what you think about a dog that's a lot
bigger than a cat as opposed to a little
fairer than they still have the same
size needles
okay
[Music]
or he stand off for sure
all right so the one I'm going to do now
is just make a little small incision but
we'll stick the needle through that way
if we don't have to puncture so hard
through the skin
yeah
there we go
sticker's ticking pretty fast all right
so now we put the implant in so you
attach that to your syringe stop yep
so we're gonna do for this rather than
put a stitch I'm gonna take a little
surgical glue and put on top here so
everybody be consistent we like to do it
on the dorsal area like right over the
shoulder blade area you look good it's
great all right we're gonna wake the
baby up good morning there you go good
morning very good come on come on here
we go
it won't happen so we're 1.6 right we're
thin you know I'd like to be at least
over two pounds two and a half pounds
hey you got to get up over two pounds
but oh you're drunk right now huh you
can't do a drinking though you have to
eat basically what we're gonna do now
just watch the song and see if this
thing improved even within a week we
should have more energy start eating
better start picking up weight and just
doing a whole lot better all right Mommy
we're back here he is yes
and we put a little bit of glue there
okay so but other than that everything's
good this is my first time getting this
done with any of my animals and he was
in and out in five minutes Oscar did
great he's feeling perfectly fine and I
am so glad it was something so easy we
were one point six eight six eight
pounds so I want to compare when I call
you let's see if we picking up weight I
want to know how we're doing okay thanks
guys all right thank you
[Music]
an unexpected emergency has Dr Hodges
face to face with a bearded dragon in
critical condition it's a pet rep it got
out the cave and popped him it looks
like one time we got a bearded dragon
named chippy and the wife went in this
morning to feed Jiffy I left the top off
his cage and one of our pet rats got in
the cage and attacked him beat him on
the side of his neck and skull
it was pretty bad situation at the house
we're gonna get him fixed hey I need
that one bounce
what's going on
the first thing you want to do is clean
this area off so you know exactly what
you're looking at well you definitely
got some head trauma for sure either
closed and keep on the road because
these equilibrium is off doesn't feel
normal he wants to roll over
I don't know what's going on with the
brain yeah I really need to know what's
going on in this head wound right now
you ready bro you ready let's make sure
him have a skull fracture the chippies
fracture and it's damage to the brain
you may be passed safe
to write through the school
same good boss
okay man it definitely went right
through the school I'm gonna give you my
shot but I mean it went right through
Shippy the bearded dragon clings to life
after suffering a fractured skull from a
rat bite for muscle bit on the side call
it here and then caught them back there
and see if I I'm getting myself a pain
and some fluid reptiles don't really
give any signs of pain but imagine
someone shot a nail gun through your
brain this is what chip is experiencing
now so I have to give something for pain
hopefully that pain medicine kicks in a
little while just trying to give him a
warm bath trying to get some fluency in
them okay they will absorb water it's
got a little Blood also gave him
something to stop the hopefully decrease
the swelling on the brain I'm gonna
scrub it up a little bit more I'm trying
to hydrate chipper by putting them into
warm water but also worried about too
much swelling in the brain so I'm
actually giving her diuretic so that we
don't get any more inflammatory response
inside the skull
and scrub that up yeah we just scrub it
up a little bit and then give me some
stuff for sipping man anything you can
do to help myself I got you boss man I
got a little boy
I get it we're gonna do everything we
can
[Music]
I'm using surgical glue to close this
wound because the last thing I need is
for a six-year-old to lose his best
friend
all right
polish kind of just keep them there keep
them up keep his head up keep him warm
come on yes sir but the truth is I've
done everything I can so just a terrible
game well you can see now I've gotten it
clean I got antibiotics started I got
him something on pain I'm gonna keep him
hydrated okay we're gonna say I pray
this keep our fingers crossed and see if
we can do our best I pulled some
Miracles before so I'm gonna do
everything I can all right man all right
you want to say bye my biggest concern
right now is is Chippy gonna make it or
is he not so I guess you guys to call me
yes sir if not it's gonna kill my son
it's in God's hands basically right now
see you later buddy
Dr Ferguson Sierra and Jordan are on
their way to see about a mini horse and
the not so many problems how you doing
hi how you doing all right hello young
lady how are you gonna tell us what's
going on you tell Dr Ferguson Scooter's
got a knot on her back do you know what
happened
she does her Skeeter is about four
months old she has a knot on her
shoulder back kind of area I kept
thinking she'd grow out of it it just
never went away they've not been there
the whole time within the first month I
would say it was probably the least
enlarged or anything it's kind of
growing with her I've never seen
anything like it I've been coaches for
20 something years I don't know what it
is you got my mind turning everything's
turning up here like okay what's going
on so let's take a look let's see what
we got let's see what we're gonna do
today it's a real mystery found a lump
in a pony at this age we have to find
out what this thing is it's right here
you know initially when you're here we
got a bumper we got a lump we think
about an abscess we got an area that has
some plus and a bacteria so what I want
to do here is try to get a couple of
needle samples and just see what we get
in the needle what it looks like and
then we'll make a plan from there
oh what you think it might be
[Laughter]
save me some money
we have to decide if we're dealing with
an abscess or some irregular bone
formation Facebook I'm trying to do is
see if we can get any sales out of this
thing to help us with some
identification sometimes we'll just get
fluid in here sometime we'll get pus in
there you ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
so it doesn't take a lot you can see
there's something on there so the first
step is we're gonna send these slides in
depending on what that said if it's
inconclusive we need to get in and get
x-rays but tell me man this is what this
is we make a plan from there all right
we have a medical mystery that we have
to figure out how to solve definitely
odd yeah
Dr Ferguson can find
out it's going to go away or if it's
something that she's going to live with
the rest of her life so we can prepare
for her future
the cute little family right there they
are I don't even like chips but the
little girl meals tonight yes yes
remind me of you nah she wasn't me
[Music]
thank you
she acted like she was gonna start to
push she's done that twice okay she
looks like she's going into a soft
contraction but she won't actually push
anything out this morning Layla had
puppy number one and we kind of stalled
out Layla had no progression whatsoever
from then on we're concerned that we've
got another puppy that's trapped in the
canal that can't pass and allow the
others to come through everybody's in
trouble from all of the puppies to Layla
that's my baby and my baby's fixing to
have babies
very emotional
let's get these puppies out of here
you just wouldn't deliver them from him
I'd walk into the clinic this morning
I'm still in my street clothes and I run
into some cold clients and they tell me
Layla the beautiful German Shepherd had
a puppy but she hadn't had another one
in 24 hours and I know there's a whole
lot more in there so I gotta get those
puppies out ASAP okay Dr Hodges about to
have a C-section I'm gonna need all
hands on deck
all right let's see what we got here
so we're doing okay yeah
of the problem child sometimes animals
calcium is a little bit low and the
uterus doesn't contract so we have to go
in and intervene and do a cesarean
section so I'm making an incision right
here at the base near the cervix this
one is actually tight in here come on
out of there big puppy come on out of
there hey hey first I'm coming out good
grace I need to call you King come
on you got your pump ready and
everything yep it's all ready over there
all right we got some work cut out here
come on here come on
my way
come on big but you ain't letting come
how we doing boss nothing yet buddy
getting a lot of food out there you know
this is one whole button oh wow yes this
is one plus German Shepherd puppies are
typically pretty big but these guys were
really big and I see why they didn't
quite make it through the pivot Canal
there you go there we go all right we
might have something all right puppy
number two coming your way all right you
got two you're okay baby geez maybe I
should call you
[Music]
I need you to hop on this one
all right we're gonna do something man
tell them we're gonna be all right
meconium is a thick Tire feces that's
typically released after birth
oftentimes when a pregnancy is stalled
the puppet will usually release this
into the set so essentially the puppy is
trapped in a sack with his own poop
which can suffocate it
talk to me boss no respiration yet that
wasn't kind of rough shape man yes sir
just got a lot of fluid you know as long
as so we're trying to get this baby to
talk to us come on come on we'll talk to
me now come on
oh yeah you got that little boy I got
one that I'm gonna have to do an
umbilical hernia here I mean he got a
whole everything's hanging out this poor
puppy's intestines is actually coming
out of where the normal umbilical cord
would be get this one up and then I'm
gonna bring him back and try to fix this
thing here it's a mess if I can't get
these intestines back in really quickly
this pup is definitely gonna die
make sure you keep this on I mean his
whole everything hurting you so I need
to get him up and then I'm gonna bring
him back and fix it as Layla the German
Shepherd undergoes an emergency
C-section several of her pups struggle
to survive I ain't never seen that in 20
years I got a pup coming out with
meconium I got a pup that's unfortunate
come out that has his intestines out of
his body this has been a really really
high stakes labor that stimulate you
here come on man you've been sleeping
long enough it's time to get up now man
see we got a problem with this one too
coming your way y'all got a free hand
that's all hardness that's it boss I
mean we have a one two three four five
six four of them doing pretty good right
now we're working on two trying to get
them going here they have a heartbeat
and they had a lot of fluid in them so
we try to get those lungs all cleared up
you already got puppy breaths see how my
hernia one doing it's not great yet
this puppy has a hole and literally
through this hole the intestines are
actually coming out
[Applause]
Justin's everywhere how we doing they're
doing good when intestines are exposed
and the whole what we call peritoneal
cavity it is exposed you get peritonitis
and peritonitis is an infection in the
abdomen and it's oftentimes fatal maybe
the weather a little bit though yeah
please drop some Saloon I'm also worried
about these intestines drying out if
these intestines dry out or damaged some
kind of way this puppet doesn't stand a
chance
come on puppy I ain't never done this
before bro
like I ain't doing something to get that
in there someone
I just can't get I can't get to my
hernia ring this is harder than doing a
C-section a hernia ring is actually the
combination of what we call fascia and
muscle tissue that has become weak and
an intestine or fatty tissue comes right
through how's it going man a little
tough go in there closing the hernia
typically it's not terribly hard but
closing the hernia in an area about the
size of a toothpick is really testing my
medical expertise you don't want to go
Duty
ah
come on largest
he was there in there I don't know if
you're close right now
I think he got it there
[Music]
yeah
yeah I didn't think it was gonna go but
intestines back in took a few years off
here at least a few days a long time man
I'm tough so I'm good now though
you got it now I don't think y'all know
how much we appreciate y'all y'all are
amazing yeah well that's what we're here
for
[Music]
a deal
I feel the heartbeat I got so emotional
and I know if I didn't get those
intestines in this though
when to live but I couldn't stop trying
I was asking for miracle
I got in I didn't think it was gonna go
it's all good
[Music]
hopefully it's purpose okay I did my
best
just a little challenge
start out small and we're gonna pass up
everybody
I just was able to work his magic and we
have a healthy puppy you know two three
years of my life
I've been up for 48 hours Layla's been
in labor for 72. she can now rest and
heal
and take care of her babies and watch
them grow that's your babies
[Music]
so I stopped and picked up a little
Heaven hand here hey Nicole hello you're
not missing class are you no it's not
until six okay you have to be a good
student first before anything else so
I'll train the wheel tonight or at least
you know what to say which one I love it
so we're headed back out to see Skeeter
you know he had that lump on his back
yeah so got those results back in this
actually inconclusive the first sample
that we took from Skeeter after sending
to the lab it was inconclusive so
getting a biopsy would definitely tell
me whether we were really dealing with a
hematoma which is basically just an
accumulation of sales something that's
benign or we are dealing with cancer
[Music]
thinking a difference in the size that's
probably the same it's not the same Dr
Ferguson and I talked after he got the
results of the first labs and I did not
expect to hear the word you know
malignant benign I expected no cancer
returns at all so what we plan on doing
is trying to see if we can get a little
biopsy sample of it okay and then take a
look at that and try to be a little more
definitive and then we'll talk about
options okay on where we go from there
the difficult they're doing the Box on
Amazon's awake is the ammo's awake so we
have to use a variety of medication
local anesthetic as well as we have to
restrain well I brought three texts with
me today to make sure that this Pony
stays where it needs to be so I can
perform my procedure making marks like a
plastic surgeon yeah so I'll make sure
I'm inside you know once I get a local I
won't know where it is
all right here we go ready for this
injections
oh yeah don't like that huh I'm going to
put a local anesthetic around the area
where I want to take the biopsy from so
that it's as painless as it can be so
you don't feel future pokes okay
what I don't want to do is have to give
a general anesthesia for a procedure
that's only going to last about five
minutes ready
the jobs theater to get this box I
really want to go deep into that growth
so I can get a good enough sample so
when the report comes back I feel
comfortable with the report
foreign
I will definitely be anxious to get the
results back
um on this biopsy what we're going to do
what's best for her in the end it's not
about us it's about her and her quality
of life and and her living her best life
hopefully it comes back benign I'll wait
to hear you have that report back then
we'll contact you and then we'll make
plans from there okay we'll just play it
day by day and see what we can do
I just never expected in four month old
to have maybe a cancer
[Music]
Dr Ferguson has Skeeters biopsy results
hey hey how you doing
good got your results back
no cancer so everything looks good
we got the best results we could ask for
the lump on Skeet is back came back
benign it looks smaller lasted how's it
looking now
say no large or anything like that yeah
well great I suspect this lump on
Skeeter go down on its own and Marissa's
daughter would have Skeeter for a long
time so I think we should do it just let
the baby keep living and let's just see
how it goes it shouldn't cause any issue
if it does give me a holler but that's
good news we don't have to do anything
else
yes ma'am all right so give Skeeter a
hug and if you need anything you let me
know
[Music]
I went the wrong way
man you remember that bearded dragon
that came in when it's holding his head
yeah it definitely went right through
the school I pulled some Miracles before
so I'm gonna do everything I can
[Music]
hey buddy I got them before it is not
just blood it was kind of seep and glue
and everything right it's not sleeping
anymore come here everybody
Tippy looks great today from where we
brought him in
he's moving around a lot better he still
has a little head issue with him but uh
I think we're gonna be good I think he's
happy you're here huh if you put him
flat and he can balance he'll actually
pivot keep doing the bass all weekend if
you can do three or four warm do them
okay that's gonna keep him hydrated it's
a miracle that chip is still alive
but it's going to take a lot of Nursing
and TLC to stay that way how often are
you feeding him a day oh two three times
yeah we have bug tweezers and we'll get
him some tiny some extra small crickets
yeah I think that's great if you eat it
I'll be so happy this pet is very
special to little Trey so to know that
Chip is going home with Trey even if
he's with him just one more day it makes
all the hard work worth it you try the
Crickets do it bad
and you make it work
[Music]
easy well man he might he might he's
he'd be running around your room and you
know you never know he gets to come home
he he gets to come to home today yeah
I'm so glad that I have my best
friendship me back tell me what we're
gonna do first we're gonna go get him
some what
do you think I should try to put him on
my nose no I don't think you need to put
them on your nose right now
[Music]
the good news is a very sweet cat and
has worms now here's the bad news Dr
Hodges speaks to a client who dropped
off their newly adopted cat they found
limping in a parking lot it appears to
have a broken leg like shattered at the
top and probably one of the worst spots
it can be while it was dropped off this
morning to see exactly what was going on
they found it in a shopping Center
parking lot so they don't really have
any history but after examining wallet I
noticed man it's a broken leg
all right all right I guess I'll come
oh man what you got
this cat got hit by a car looking at
Wallace x-rays unfortunately splitting
or actually trying to put a pin in
wouldn't really be an option because
this leg is actually shattered it would
be a very very long painful process I
can do a couple options but you have to
make a choice what's best for this
animal I don't know if that will form a
fibrous joint there so hippie left with
one option amputation is probably going
to be the best bit
I mean he'll walk out of here oh it'll
do fine and now it has a home so I guess
that's a game plan we'll amputate all
right make the thing better all right
all right while this leg is fragmented
into pieces so amputation is probably
going to be the best outcome to relieve
this item from pain
night night but it's okay doing a
amputation there won't be any pain or
arthritis while it will be sound and
probably run around in a few days
all right give me 10 minutes we'll give
you some food that's probably where the
car hit in the impact cause I can feel
the bone here and that feels bad hey
look bad I'm just hoping when I get in
there that it's not so booger up so it
actually fractured across the bone you
could actually see sharks well it's
nasty so I'm worried about that for more
artery oftentimes when you go in for a
surgery with an amputation and a leg is
just busted apart you gotta think there
are really really a lot of big veins and
the femoral artery is there and it is
really one of the bigger artists in the
actual body so you have to be really
really careful you cut that more harder
that's bad news if that happens
lose cattle dog
all right I'm looking for that gardening
thing Dr Hodges is carefully amputating
Wally the cat's left hind leg I was a
nerve the big nerve there
sometimes you hit cutting that in the
legs wax your job all right
oh boy poor cat so it actually fractured
across the bone sheared all the way off
yeah he was in some tremendous pain pain
tolerance is amazing I would have been
crawling on the floor
so this is where it broke actually off
putting that together
get this piece of the quadricep and to
join the rest of his quadriceps friends
it should fit together like a glove
ah
[Music]
oh how you feel man that's better I
think it took everything out of me now
everything went well the league was
really really in bad shape I mean it was
just crumbled up but gonna wake up and
by this afternoon I expect for this cat
to be walking look good no more chips in
the parking lot you good to go boss
[Music]
[Applause]
you remember that German Shepherd that
came in that was just filled with
puppies yeah come on our big puppy you
need to call you can't come here okay
baby but those are some big dogs now
well hey there you go all the babies
with the mama
Layla's doing great she did great with
her babies I couldn't be more happy with
them with the puppies with her
we definitely wouldn't have the healthy
puppies that we do without Dr Hodges and
Dr Ferguson and his team I wouldn't
change anything for the world it's
amazing
[Music]
I just you remember the cat that was
found in the parking lot we called him
Wally whatever happened to wallet well I
don't know if that were former fibers
joint there so ajp left with one option
amputation is probably going to be the
best bit
doing really well you know man it's
amazing I mean how how well these cats
do or any animals do with three legs
it's like nothing happened life-saving
surgery exactly hey good morning what's
up with my parking lot man he's ready
for that cone to come off too I'm pretty
sure let's see sorry but here we go
while he's doing great he's been
climbing all over the furniture and he's
chasing all the other cats around more
than the food than they want him to that
looks really good oh yeah
you would have thought Wally was born
with three legs and he's been used to it
this whole time oh oh yeah nothing ever
happened yeah you you ready to go
we've been going to Dr Hodges since
they've been here and I knew Wally was
going to be in good hands whenever we
brought him here you good to go my
friend perfect tripod
I've never seen a three-legged cat
before and the first one I get to see is
ours which is awesome Wally's definitely
part of the family now he's here to stay
[Music]
come on I got you after a little R and R
she's ready to go home it's time for
this wild owl to return from where she
came welcome back to your area because
uh Teresa we found it in is there
yourself yeah so that's why we chose
this area right so she'll have plenty of
food this all is doing so much better
thanks to all the hard work that Tara
has done and Omar has done you know when
you brought it in I was really worried
about us because he had just a Starry
Eyed and gave some beers and I was able
to get some of the swelling now and I
felt like okay it's time to release her
to Omar's Care Rehab is especially as
soon as I came to see her I was just
like goodness whenever we took her to
the rehab facility she took off she was
tearing up and so are we originally
thought it was a pelvis issue it clearly
wasn't it as soon as he got that start
out a concussion under control she's
wanted to go this bird pupillary light
response is much better the bird is able
to stalk his prey the pelvic wounds as
well as the skull fractures are starting
to heal that'll take a little bit more
time but this bird is is ready to go
into the beautiful George guys let's let
her go out here in this beautiful Pond
let's do it doctor all right so I'm
going to kind of hold for it and I'll
let you lift the top I'll kind of hold
it here all right see you later all
right baby girl all right three two one
there she is she's ready
hey man that's what it's all about thank
you so much I see your fly away I'm
looking at her flapper Wings I'm looking
at the wingspan I'm looking at the
movement
I have no doubt this bird is going to be
fine
20 years as a veterinarian
my first time releasing a owl first time
working on uh but that's what it's all
about
[Music]